hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the semi-finals of
the junior speed Chess Championship it
is Prana versus gukesh and this is a
game from the blitz section but also as
there are a couple of Blitz sections
this is five plus three there's also the
three plus two I believe and then
there's one plus one so same as uh in
the general speeches Championship only
this is the junior speeches championship
and it's again uh one of those games
that shows us how you should always play
the Evans Gambit otherwise uh well bad
things will happen as they always do so
let's check it out pranav has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to E4 we
have Pawn to E5 Knight to F3 Knight to
C6 and now Bishop to C4 going for the
Italian game Bishop to C5 The Joker
piano and now Pawn to C3 not going for
the strongest move but Pawn to C3 the
main line of the Joker piano Knight to
F6 and now Pawn to D4 striking in the
center uh e captures on D4 and now Pawn
to E5 this is the center attack and and
black pretty much has only one good
reply and that is Pawn to D5 now uh I
remember in the olden days when I was
only beginning to play chess I I loved
to play this with white if for some
reason I didn't go for the evidence
Gambit you know it was it was rare but
uh there were some uh instances where
for example I didn't know idiot existed
then I didn't go for it and then I
wouldn't play the strongest Bishop to B5
move I would take and then my opponent
would take and I would think that I was
always better but white is never better
in positions like these okay you will
capture here black will play Rook to G8
and you will even castle and it looks
really good you've messed up his Pawn
structure and everything but let's say
black plays D3 you can play rookie one
check black will defend then Bishop to
E6 comes then the queen is default black
Castle's Queen side and uh you just have
to deal with the the pass Pawn on D3 for
a very long time okay we'll undermine it
would be three but still it's gonna be
very hard for white to play this so
instead after this D5 move the absolute
best is Bishop to B5 if any of you are
are still playing this instead of the
Evans game but just uh you know so you
know uh Knight the E4 and now C captures
on D4 attacking the bishop with Bishop
to B6 and now Knight to C3 is the
absolute Mainline Bishop D3 the second
most popular moves are still very very
strong and the bishop to G4 by Goo cash
and now there is a game from 2017 from
the world uh Blitz champion from the
Chinese uh Blitz championship between uh
jungle one and yishu that ended by black
winning but here we have Pawn to H3 and
it is now as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game so okay Bishop to H5
by Gucci now Knight to C3 we have
castles finally uh and uh White also
castles and here
uh you have to figure out do you want to
capture on D4 or not because it is
possible uh problem is it yields only a
draw if Knight captures on D4 it's a
really uh wild line okay you can't move
the Knight the Knight is obviously
pinned Bishop captures on D4 and now
Bishop captures on F3 now the White
Queen cannot capture because the bishop
captures on D4 uh so you'll play
g-captress on F3 and now Queen to G5
with with check I will force a draw King
to H1 now Queen to F5 going for the H3
pawn and uh that's pretty much it let's
save captures an E4 Queen captures an E3
check King to G1 and now you just play
Bishop capture Sunday for Queen captures
and now Queen to G4 check and the queen
will force a draw with Queen H for Queen
to G4 and so on so that looks nice but
nothing more than a draw so instead
bookish plays Pawn to F5 Pawn to F6 also
playable as it um
offers more choices it also puts
pressure on White Center so black can
capture and open MDF file but Google
decides to play it like this Pawn to F5
and now we have Knight the E2 a very
interesting move as it allows the
capture on F3 what uh probably should
have been played here is just e-capters
and F6 Alpha Song and then the idea was
of course Knight captures B captures and
queen captures putting this immense
pressure on the F3 Knight okay let's say
Bishop D2 sorry Bishop D2 and Rook 88
black gets a full mobilization of his
pieces but you know it's a game and no
one is better here but instead after a
five pound I've tried a knight to E2 now
if you don't react of course the Knight
is coming to F4 so Bishop captures an F3
uh G captures and now Knights to G5
putting pressure on both F3 and H3 and
here uh how do you defend well best
would be F4 it was not played in the
game but it would be best and now if
Knight to F3 check you simply attacked
the Knight there's no time for the queen
to get into the game but instead the
king the G2 use played right away and
now Pawn to F4 this is a spectacular
move by gookish uh it seems like upon
sacrifice but not really you are
undermining the D4 Pawn by removing one
of the Defenders
uh so Knight captures an F4 Knight
captures on D4 yeah with Bishop capture
Sandy for uh Bishop D2 was uh maybe a
little bit better but okay it's Blitz
Bishop captures on D4 and now Rook
captures on F4 now even puts more
pressure on the F3 pawn bishop back to
E3 attacks the rook and now Rook
captures an F3 I'm just gonna show it
because it's a lot of fun Knight
captures on H3 is instant uh resigns
says there's no good way to defend this
Quint H4 is coming next uh if if you
capture the Knight and of course if you
capture here then Knight captures an F4
check and it's a force Checkmate doesn't
matter where you go let's say King to H1
the queen is coming to H4 with the check
and that's pretty much it King G1 Queen
G3 with checking the H1 and queen to G2
with Checkmate and all of the other
moves aren't much better so after Knight
captures an H3 there's really not all
that much you can do but okay like I
said once again it's Blitz after Bishop
T3 Rook captures and F3 was played and
now Bishop captures and G5 uh the final
mistake but it wasn't salvageable either
way so Queen captures ng5 was played
King captures an F3 and now Rook the f8
with check we have King the E2 and now
feel free to pause the video and try to
finish this King hunt for gookish while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
beautiful move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show indeed it is
mate in four and that is a rook captures
on F2 this is what glucose played and he
was in this position on move 21 uh that
kind of resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here there are a
couple of moves you could play if you
capture with the Rook uh it doesn't
really do all that much Queen E3 check
only move King to F1 and queen
characters and F2 will be Checkmate you
could also ignore the Rook placing the
E1 but still Queen to E3 with check you
can block with the bishop even but now
Rook captures an F1 with check on the
movies King characters and then Queen to
F2 or G1 will be Checkmate you know it
all depends on um what you prefer and of
course if you play uh if you just go up
the board King to D3 then a nice Queen
to E3 will also be Checkmate so there
you have it a white uh went for the main
line the calm line of the Joko piano and
lost in 21 moves um after a Google
beautifully played this world captures
an F2 move but again you could also play
the Evans Gambit and you know you you
might also lose but you will you know
you you will fight for Glory and
immortality uh so yeah that's the guy
again hope you guys enjoyed it uh also
uh you know if you if you ever
encountered this if you play uh the the
bishop to C5 line and your opponent does
not go uh for the for the strongest move
you will now know how to punish them if
they uh you know misbehave a little bit
in the middle game uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it uh I
would like to thank Mason uh David
quintillion uh John Anderson Daniel
tayako and Andrea lucnicko for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and everything
else that's happening in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and yeah I realize I still I haven't
fixed John's name uh so sorry about that
Mr John I will do it right now uh that
is no way uh no way to you know and
behave so there we go
all right John's name is now full uh the
you know the force has been restored and
uh we can now end the video properly uh
see you soon